welcome back time for the fastest first
up talk about getting an upgrade bradley
cooper is reportedly dating huma abedin
the top clinton confidant trading her
pervy ex-husband anthony weiner for an
a-lister greg
who dareth to tread where the wiener
doth tread
i don't believe this for one second this
is fake news i don't know
why they're doing this but it just
doesn't make any sense to me i mean
it's got to be i mean why is it why
doesn't it make sense because anthony
weiner was such a prize and to move on
to some trash
some trash like bradley cooper i mean
let's be honest i mean talk about like
she's really going downhill yeah and
anna wintour was the matchmaker i'm sure
this is forever yes i love this really
romantic statement from the source on
this story they are perfect for each
other they're both into power politics
and human affairs like isn't that what
you always say when two great people
that you love fall for each other how
fake is that quote that it's like if
you're gonna do anonymous gossip quotes
kind of make it sound like a human being
geez leading with power
is kind of the tell though and probably
the most accurate part of the whole
thing because that's what these often
turn out to be i was surprised by it
though um
that it was even a fake potentially a
fake thing it's covering up something
jesse i just wanted to take another look
at you oh i i thought maybe this was
real now you guys
are making me feel
wow naive
has your innocence been crushed
i mean listen there's i don't know what
he's doing get anthony on your show to
talk about this i know should i have
weiner on the show yes i tried he said
no to me he said no to you yes he did
try prime time
all right yeah weiner if you're watching
yeah you know actually no it's fine
he is the biggest jackass i've ever met
here at work the biggest jackets all the
people you've met here at work the
biggest the stone cold jackass do you
remember when that he had presidential
ambitions used to come on all the time
you know why i say that because he used
to belittle and talk down to the people
who work in our green rooms and there's
nowhere no lower low than that to be
fair those people are jerks
i'm being devil's advocacy
again one more thing what i do next hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now